so far henry cavill has not been able to
convince 100% in his role as supermen
after the relatively successful debut in
Man of Steel the film's Batman vs
Superman dawn of Justice and Justice
League followed which were controversial
among critics and fans no wonder that
Warner Brothers put cavil and his
character Superman on hold for the time
being as deadline now reports contrary
to all expectations a return of Superman
seems to be imminent in any case this is
not supposed to be a big solo film
because according to the latest media
reports Warner is negotiating with cavil
about a rather small appearance in an
already announced movie but which films
are actually suitable for Carroll's
return for Wonder Woman 1984 and The
Suicide Squad the shooting has already
been completed and also for the Batman
an appearance of the 37 year old seems
to very unlikely in a much earlier
production face there are Aquaman 2
black atom or even chasm 2 in all three
of them an appearance of Superman could
be included even though there is no
reliable information about three movies
yet because of the missing story quite
interesting as the fact that a long time
ago a montage by the artist boss logic
appeared where Superman and Black Adam
are seen during a fight both of them
seem to be in not too good shape and the
picture after pretty bad fight
although Superman at least seems to have
the air supremacy on his side the cool
about this is that boss logic probably
didn't create this picture entirely of
his own free will
he's supposed to have been specifically
requested by the rocks team to create a
picture of Superman fighting off Black
Adam according to the artist himself it
seemed strange to him because why would
the rock explicitly ask for a picture
where he himself was attacked what do
you think is just a nice looking fan art
or is there may be more to it we will
find out more about it in the near
future after all the shooting of Black
Adam is about to start the US release of
Black Adam is planned for December 22nd
2021 a few weeks ago we reported that
avatar director James Cameron was not at
all satisfied with the status quo caused
by the pandemic due to massive
restrictions the production of his
sequel avatar 2 which is scheduled to be
released at the end of 2021 stagnated a
few days ago producer Jon Landau
announced that his return to New Zealand
was imminent so that work on the film
could finally
be finalized the goal of course is to
maintain the production start as good as
possible according to the New Zealand
radio station Radio New Zealand a
smaller team led by Lando will go to the
alan for the time-being
to restart production they will then
serve the two we quarantine together so
far so good but John Landau didn't miss
the chance to reveal some more details
about this story of the avatar a
successor the story revolves around the
family of Jake and a theory already
known from the first part according to
lend out they are forced to leave their
homes in the second part afterwards they
will explore different regions of
pandora including an underwater world
this is also in line with the pictures
of avatar 2 which were published a few
months ago and give a good foretaste of
the upcoming impressive regions of
pandora avatar 2 is expected to be
released in u.s. cinemas on December
17th 20 21 and the sequels avatar 3 4
and 5 will be released every two years
one week ago the time had come the
Snyder kind of Justice League which has
been demanded for years was officially
announced for 2021 could this now
initiate a way for similar films seems
like it because a few days after the
announcement there was already rumors
about an air cat for the 2016 release
movie Suicide Squad sounds reasonable
because they are often stressed in the
past that he's not at all that satisfied
with the final cinema version when the
director was asked on Twitter by
journalist Steven Weintraub what an air
cut for Suicide Squad would look like he
answered promptly literally he said this
is a good question my cut would be easy
to complete it will be incredibly
cathartic for me it's exhausting getting
your ass kicked for a film that got the
Edward Scissorhands treatment the film I
made has never been seen so motivation
and enough raw material for an air cat
are definitely there now it's probably
up to the net community again to use
hashtags like release the air cut to
make sure Warner Brothers becomes active
what do you think about the emerging
trend of releasing well-known films in
different versions for your money making
or a fresh perspective on already
released films feel free to write in the
comments for a long time it was quieter
out Matt Damon's character Jason Bourne
in the action movie series of the same
name the former CIA contract killer was
last seen in the cinemas in
20:16 before that jeremy renner briefly
took over the character and the spin-off
the Bourne Legacy in 2012 since then it
has become more or less quiet around the
film series which has existed since 2002
from time to time you could hear
something about a sixth part but the
work behind the scenes probably didn't
make much progress however the producer
in charge of the series is now raising
new hopes for a sequel in an interview
with Collider producer frank marshall
talked about the current status of the
project and was quite optimistic about
the future of the franchise according to
his own statement the production team is
currently looking for director and a new
story
unfortunately Marshall did not want to
reveal whether Matt Damon would then
return for the sixth part nevertheless
it remains to be hoped after all it
became clear during the spin-off with
jeremy renner both in terms of reviews
and financially that a Bourne film
simply doesn't work probably without
Jason Bourne so whether we will see a
six part depends mainly on finding a
capable director and a thrilling story
at least the producer seems to be
optimistic the fantasy adventure film
labyrinth with David Bowie has long
become a classic for many people and it
seems that Tristar studio is now
actually announcing a second part with
Doctor Strange director scott derrickson
according to a report by deadline
derrickson is indeed given the honour to
continue the movie which was released 34
years ago this will come in handy for
him after all the creative disagreement
and his departure from Disney is not
that long ago
one thing labyrinth and Derek since last
Marvel film seemed to have at least in
common the word strange applies to both
of them quite well in the genre classic
labyrinth which was released in 1984
David Bowie made a name for himself with
a performance as the desing goblin king
most of his co-stars are Muppets because
how could it be any other way Jim Hanson
directed the show is not only a director
but also a puppeteer besides the movie
with a David Bowie Henson all to let the
puppets dance at the Muppet Show and at
Sesame Street in terms of content
labyrinth is about the teenager Sarah
who is so annoyed by her little brother
Toby then she prefers to escape into
dreamworld as a result she wishes that
her brother would be kidnapped by
goblins no sooner said than done
that's not exactly what Sarah had meant
after all because she immediately leaves
to free her little brother
from the goblins clutches she has to
cross a labyrinth under great time
pressure otherwise her brother will turn
into a goblin as well so much for the
first part how the story will be
continued in the second part is not
known at the moment but according to
Deadline it should at least be
definitely a sequel not a remake when we
can expect a release is not yet known
[Music]